dominique you had one of i think one of
the greats carrie washington praising
your portrayal of deborah johnson she
said your performance was glorious girl
how does that feel it's definitely honor
i can't say that it's not you know a lot
of times we like to remove ourselves and
say i don't care what people think but
we definitely put our hearts and souls
into this project
i'm gonna share something with you
like the masses i wasn't
all when i first laid eyes on all the
things you all
i heard that speech i knew we make noise
i just thought it'd be in the streets we
knew the
importance of us telling our own stories
and how much weight it was and the fact
that the family was involved
so i thought so i'm just i'm excited one
that care washington would say that
excited too that the
family would feel like we represented
them well so that being said shaka talk
to us a little bit about
how it was having fred hampton's family
involved in this
in this project oh it was a blessing you
know
um it was always challenging
for us to figure out a way to
you know honor the historical record um
you know highlight the things that
chairmanship hampton drew and aku and
jerry thought were important
um and and of always i mean even before
we
made contact with them it was important
to us to just
make sure that we we honored the legacy
of the people uh in the film
um but you know it was incredibly
rewarding to just have them be able to
chime in about
you know potential pitfalls that we
could stumble into
and mistakes we could make things that
we might find or think we're innocuous
that
you know are not at all and so it was we
were lucky that
that they took that ride with us and i
know it was sometimes difficult for them
as well
the goal was always to find points of
interest between you know myself the
producer's
studio and chairman for hampton junior
in a cool nigerian
ultimately you know we were able to do
that and they still
speak with us they still you know we
talk all the time you know so it's
that's that's a good sign you know
yeah from my research it definitely
seems like perfect timing played a part
in this
because i've see i've seen articles on
the fact that they tried something
similar before but for some reason this
was just the perfect fit
or the perfect way to tell his story in
a recent interview dominique you
mentioned that
taking on the role of deborah johnson
which is fred hampton's partner
you realized what type of woman you
wanted to be
can you expound a little bit on that
yeah
i think just coming from from brooklyn
from east new york and even navigating
this industry
as a woman you start picking up the
habits that you have to be on guard all
the time
you know you have to defend yourself and
i remember we went to go speak to
the family before we went filming and um
mama akua said the panthers were very
disciplined
the discipline they didn't speak out of
turn and there was some things that she
wouldn't say to
chairman fred that we were saying in the
movie and
she's so fiery she says whatever's on my
christian out like this you know what i
mean
how could she feel that way about these
little like this is not even
big in my in my own mind and as i
watched dave take up space and learned
more about chairman fred i said oh he
inspired people to trust him and when
you trust people you don't have to be on
guard and you don't have to be defensive
and i learned with my cast and my crew
and shaka that i don't have to be
defensive
and that there's always somebody that's
going to be having my back and
advocating
advocating for me and i don't have to do
it in the same ways that i've done it
before
i can receive i can receive love and i
can receive support
so then it just influenced how i wanted
to move in the world
when i got back home to brooklyn wow
that gives me chills i feel like for you
listening to all your interviews i know
probably for all of you but specifically
for you dominique
this was a spiritual experience for you
definitely
and it definitely grew you in ways that
you just didn't even imagine
yeah i feel like i was i feel like it's
so it's so interesting because i call
like the the boys club
but i felt that i was on a threshold of
womanhood and the idea concept of i
didn't know what it was but i felt like
i was teetering some kind of line
and this embodying mama couldn't buy in
the spirit of deborah johnson
and the love that she shared with
chairman fred allow me to cross
over that threshold especially with
having a partner like daniel who i think
his superpower is he's able to see
people for
who they are and where they're at and
he's able to remove his ego and meet
people where they are
and i said that's a big deal and so he
knows how to
he knows how to care about people no
matter if i'm playing his partner or
just in general the people around him
and shout out to daniel for that golden
globe nomination
shaka you've been working on this film
based off of my research from 2016.
it's been a long journey for you how do
you feel like
you've changed how do you feel like this
experience has grown
you it's tough to say because you know
like the last four years of my life
with the film and just other life stuff
has been i feel like i've lived like a
good
solid three lives you know there's also
the pandemic life
right you know which is another life you
know um
so it's tough to say is i know it has
changed me in the true
a million ways probably some for the
better probably some for the worse
um but um but yeah i'm
definitely a completely different person
than i was when i started making this
movie
how much of this film is accurate i know
it's history so you can't get every
detail right but if you can just let
viewers know
how much is accurate i mean it's tough
to quantify you know
um i think certainly the ideas put
forward by fred hampton
we tried to use his words as often as
possible
um you know and we started i think
there's only one speech that we
have where his words are you know
i mean they're not even fully altered
they're just like kind of like minor
tweaks
and that was because we didn't have the
life rights until the second week of
filming
um when fred hampton jr and chairman's
right hand junior nicole and jerry came
on board as cultural consultants so we
tried to use his words as often as
possible there
there were some names of characters that
had to be changed
there's some characters that are
invented um
you know uh for example the character of
judy harmon
played by dominique thorne as a hybrid
of you know
different women who were in the panthers
just because the illinois chapter as far
as we knew
didn't have any women in the security
cadre and this is a movie that focuses
on the security cadre and we thought it
was important to have some strong women
in the film besides dominique
fishbach so we created that character um
but there's some characters who are
based on you know real characters jake
winters was a real person
obviously bobby rush was a real person
um
you know mark clark obviously was a real
person you know
who was also assassinated along with
chairman fred on december 4th so
um and william o'neill obviously is a
real person where mitchell is so
it's a it's a it's a i can't quantify it
i can't be like 60 40 or 70 30.
i know that at our first draft was like
99 percent true it was also but it was
also like 250 pages you know
so when you have to get this to a
makeable place
you start having to make some some
changes and sacrifices
uh but it's true enough that
people who lived through this the ones
that i've spoken to
are like yeah this isn't all the way
true like it didn't happen that way but
yeah that but that happened where this
happened yeah
so yeah that's right the atrocity of it
is the truth and that's
like one of the biggest the biggest
thing that's important
that they murdered him in the bed like
that that they shot up the apartment 99
times right like and they shot through
the walls like that like i will say that
when it came to the assassination we
wanted to make it very clear that it was
an assassination and not
you know killing it was very politically
motivated and it was clear intent
and so for that reason that was one of
the scenes where we wanted to be very
precise with showing the intent that was
key
i also think like we know their ages but
we don't really know
like you know we don't let it resonate
the fact that they were 19
20 21. i think that's what hit me the
most i mean after i watched the film of
course i went down a rabbit hole
trying to learn everything about fred
hampton and the fact that he was 21
saying the words that he was saying or
even having the courage
to be as bold and willing to lose his
life
for this revolution that's
but it makes sense too at the same time
in a way because we see the people who
are now
leading on the front lines of the
revolution that's happening
now so it's always the use i think
internationally it's always you know
youth-led movements are the ones that
generally are the most revolutionary
because they don't have the trappings of
like a mortgage and you know
all this and that and the third that
they that they've acquired like
they're pure in that way yeah
yeah and they have fresh vision for the
future
what are the benefits of black directors
and creators telling black stories
specifically when it comes to our
history why is that so important
the gaze is key you know like who is
this
one of the things i would constantly be
asking myself when making decisions
about scenes is who is this
movie for who is this scene for who is
my audience
my primary audience um and you know i
think
i know for a fact that traditionally
hollywood has so they have this as a
term use the general audience
right and the general audience it the
sort of like
specific thing they're talking about is
you know every age range every year
but they really generally when they say
that they mean white people
so most movies are made for white
consumers and white consumption
and i think when you're making a movie
like this film
you know or one night in miami you know
or
the five bloods you know or
ma rainey's black bottom right like i
i think that all of those writers and
directors
they're coming from the place of okay
i'm i'm making this for
you know my mom to watch for my friends
to watch or
you know they're seeing the people who
look like them
first when they see the audience and
that changes everything
you